Dear fellow scholars. This is two minute papers with Dr. [inaudible] here.
Early 2019. A learning based technique appeared that could perform common,
natural language processing operations. For instance, answering questions,
completing text, reading, comprehension, summarization, and more.
This method was developed by scientists at open AI and they call it GPT
to a follow-up paper,
introduced a more capable version of this technique called the GBT three and
among many incredible examples.
It could generate website layouts from a written description.
The key idea in both cases was that we will provide it an incomplete piece of
text and it would try to finish it. However,
no one said that these neural networks have to only deal with text information
and sure enough,
in this work scientists at open AI introduced a new version of this method that
tries to complete not taxed bad images.
The problem statement is simple.
We give it an incomplete image and we ask the AI to fill in the missing pixels.
That is of course,
an immensely difficult task because these images made the picked any part of the
world around us.
It would have to know a great deal about our world to be able to continue the
images. So how well did it do let's have a look.
This is undoubtedly a cat bat. Look,
see that white part that is just starting.
The interesting part has been cut out of the image. What could that be?
A piece of paper or something else now let's leave the dirty work to the machine
and ask it to finish it. Wow.
The piece of paper, indeed, according to the AI and it even has taxed on it,
but attacks has a heading section and a paragraph below it to
truly excellent. You know, what is even more excellent,
perhaps the best part.
It also added the indirect illumination on the fur of the cat,
meaning that it sees that a blue room surrounds it and therefore some amount of
the color bleeds onto the fare of the cat making it blower.
I am a light transport researcher by trade.
So I spent the majority of my life calculating things like this.
And I have to say that this looks quite good to me.
Absolutely amazing attention to detail, but it had more ideas.
What's this, the face of the cat has been finished quite well, in fact,
but the rest, I am not so sure if you have an idea what this is supposed to be,
please let me know in the comments and here go the rest of the results.
All quite good.
And the true real image has been concealed for the algorithm.
This is the reference solution. Let's see the next one. Oh,
my scientists at open AI pulled no punches here.
This is also quite nasty. How many stripes should this continue with
zero? Maybe in any case, this solution is not unreasonable.
I appreciate the fact that it continued the shadows of the humans.
Next one. Yes. More stripes. Great,
but likely a few too many here are the remainder of the solutions
and the true reference image. Again,
let's have a look at this water droplet example too.
We humans know that since we see the remnants of some ripples over there too,
there must be a splash bat. Does the AI know?
Oh yes. Yes, it does. Amazing. And the true image.
Now what about these little creatures?
The first continuation finishes them correctly and puts them on a twig.
The second one involves a stone.
The third is my favorite hold onto your papers. And look at this.
They stand in the water and we can even see their mirror images.
Wow.
The fourth is a branch and finally the true reference image.
This is one of its best works. I have seen so far.
Here are some more results and note that these are not cherry-picked or in other
words, there was no selection process for the results. Nothing was discarded.
These came out from the AI. As you see them,
there's a link to these and to the paper in the video description.
So make sure to have a look and let me know in the comments,
if you have found something interesting.
So what about the size of the neural network for this technique? Well,
it contains from one and a half to about 7 billion parameters.
Let's have a look together and find out what that means.
These are the results from the GPT two paper,
the previous version of the text processor on a challenging reading
comprehension test as a function of the number of parameters.
As you see around one and a half billion parameters,
which is roughly similar to GPT two, it learned a great deal,
but its understanding was nowhere near the level of human comprehension.
However, as they grew the network, something incredible happened.
Non-trivial capabilities started to appear.
As we approached a hundred billion parameters, look,
it nearly matched the level of humans and all this was measured on a
nasty reading comprehension test.
So this image GPT has the number of parameters that is closer to GPT
two than GPT three.
So we can maybe speculate that the next version could be potentially another
explosion in capabilities. I can't wait to have a look at that.
What a time to be alive.
This episode has been supported by weights and biases in this post.
They show you how to use their system to visualize which part of the image your
neural network looks at before. It concludes that it is a cat.
You can even try an example in an interactive notebook,
through the link in the video description,
weights and biases provides tools to track your experiments in your deep
learning projects. Their system is designed to save you a ton of time and money,
and it is actively used in projects at prestigious labs,
such as open AI Toyota research GitHub and more.
And the best part is that if you have an open source academic or personal
project, you can use their tools for free. It really is as good as it gets.
Make sure to visit them through
wmb.com/papers or click the link in the video description to start tracking your
experiments in five minutes,
our thanks to weights and biases for their longstanding support and for helping
us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous support. And I'll see you next time.